Well, let me move on to Evan Gershkovich,
of course
The Wall Street Journal reporter
who has been arrested and detained
in Russia on espionage charges.
The administration has called these claims
ridiculous.
Is in the process right now
trying to get a console visit with Evan.
Has any
anything developed on that front yet?
Sadly, no, Brianna.
We have not been able to achieve consular
access and nobody from our embassy
has been able to meet with him.
We are continuing to work on that,
of course, and will
until we can get that consular access
to ascertain for ourselves
how he's doing and make sure that
that we have that connection.
But no, we haven't.
We haven't been able to gain access to him
at this time.
So there's no engagement with Evan,
no update
or status as to where he is
and how he is doing?
I'm afraid not.
I mean, we're we're doing the best
we can to get information
from the Russian government,
obviously, as much as we can.
And we have been in touch with the family
through the State Department.
And we will continue
those lines of communication
But right now, I just don't have much to
to update you on.
Of course, we are thinking about
his family and his colleagues right now.
The FSB in their statement said that Mr.
Kovac is, quote, suspected of spying in
the interests of the American government.
And this is what really struck me, John.
A Kremlin spokesperson and press
secretary, Dmitry Peskov, said that
he was, quote, caught red handed.
These are very provocative
and I would say deliberate words.
I can't
imagine that this would not have happened
without the sign off of Vladimir Putin.
Do you agree with that assessment?
We can't delink.
We can't specifically link Mr.
Putin to to this arrest.
That said, he, as you well
know, has really,
really clamped down on independent media
reporting in Russia
and just shutting down outlets,
kicking some out.
I mean, it's it's a very,
very tough environment for any kind of
independent,
independent journalism to to occur.
So he has certainly set the conditions
where it's very difficult
for free and independent reporters
to actually do their job.
And just to put a fine point on it,
you didn't ask, but
the claims, the espionage
claims against Mr.
Gersh, which are absolutely ludicrous.
He was a working journalist
for The Wall Street Journal.
And we want to see him released. Yeah.
And the administration noted yesterday
they call these claims
Karine Jean-Pierre called them ridiculous.
I know that the State Department
is in its process, which is routine
when an American is detained to
to get to the actual words and being able
to label this wrongfully detained,
where does that process stand?
I would
have to refer you to the state department.
They do have a process
that they put in place
when when we have Americans
detained overseas where they
take a look at the circumstances.
And I don't really know where they are
in that process.
It is very much driven
by individual cases.
So it's not driven by a specific timeline
necessarily.
It's really driven by, you know,
taking a look at each case individually.
And they'll do that and they'll do that
in the appropriate manner.
We're sure that in the meantime, it's
very clear that from everything
we've been able to glean that he was
simply picked up for being a reporter.
And again, in a country where being
a reporter can be a very dangerous thing.
And we want to see him released
We want to see him released right away
immediately.
That's he does not belong to be detained
for for doing the job of a reporter
in a foreign country.
Let me read to you what his employer
The Wall Street Journal has said
in their editorial and what they believe
is the government's duty now in response.
They called his detainment another example
of Russia taking a journal hostage.
Thuggish leaders
keep doing thuggish things
if they think they will pay no price.
Expelling Russia's ambassador to the U.S.,
as well as all Russian journalists,
would be the minimum
to expect the US government's first duty
is to protect its citizens,
and too many governments
now believe that they can arrest
and imprison Americans with impunity.
President Biden was asked just today
if he plans to expel
Russian journalists or diplomats.
He said there are
no plans right now. Why not?
We are taking a look at this case
obviously very closely.
Our focus right
now, Bianna, is getting Evan out of there,
getting getting him released
and working towards getting him released.
And so that's
where the focus is right now.
And I don't have anything to add
to what the president said in terms
of any consequences
that will come from this.
I think it's important
to remember a couple of things.
Number one,
this is not a new tactic for Mr.
Putin.
He has he has detained American citizens
and citizens from other countries
in a routine way on many times
sham charges.
That's number one.
Number two, President Biden never forgets
Americans that are detained overseas.
He has a whole team
here at the State Department
at the National Security Council
dedicated to getting those folks home.
And we're going to do that in Evan's case.
We're going to work just as hard for Evan
as we are for everybody else.
But each case has got to be
looked at individually.
The last thing I'll say here is
this is not the time for Americans
to be in Russia.
If you're in Russia now,
whether it's on business or leisure,
whatever kind of travel
you need to leave now.
This is not a good place
for you to be in Russia,
even if you are a working journalist.
Russia is a is a hostile environment
for American citizens right now,
and it's time to go if you're there.
So as you know,
there are several
international journalists
that are currently working inside Russia,
including Americans,
including you know, we have colleagues
who maybe not from America,
but other Western countries
reporting from Russia as well.
Is the administration's take
now that they should leave?
We can't speak for other countries
and certainly wouldn't do that.
Those are those are sovereign
nation states
that can speak for their own citizens.
And we would leave it at that.
What we're saying is and the State
Department's been extremely clear
about this on their website,
they've got a level four advisory out.
Russia is not a safe country
for Americans to travel to or to be.
And if you are in Russia, again,
we urge you to leave immediately.
You have said that you do not know if this
detention was retaliatory or perhaps.
Vladimir Putin seeking a prisoner swap,
which he's been known to do in the past.
Many experts who follow him
believe that's, in fact, part of his plan
right now.
What is the US's view on this?
Is there anybody that the U.S.
is currently detaining who would be able
to be swapped with with Evan?
We don't know exactly
what other motives
beyond what they've said publicly
for arresting and detaining.
Evan is we just
we don't have any evidence that this was
some sort of retaliatory measure
or that it is, in fact, a ploy by Mr.
Putin to do a prisoner swap.
And I won't get ahead of where we are
on the process here.
We're going to work to get Evan released,
just like we're going to work to get Paul
Whalen released
and any other detained Americans overseas.
Each case is individual.
Each case is specific.
And so I certainly wouldn't talk
about what tactics might be in play
or what options are before us
as we continue to try to work to learn
more about Evan's case.
Our main priority right now, obviously,
we'd like to see him released right now.
Of course, he doesn't need to be detained.
But our main priority is getting access
to him physically, consular access
so we can ascertain
how he's doing and and try to address
any immediate needs that he might have.
Do you have any developments?
Please do keep us posted.
I do want to move on to the war
in Ukraine in general,
because there is growing concern
about what, in fact, the U.S.
policy is vis-a-vis
the war in Ukraine from the get-Go.
The Biden administration has said
that it is about liberating Ukraine
and making sure
Russia leaves its boundaries there
and nothing would be done
without Ukraine involved.
That having been said,
there is speculation that going forward
and any sort of assistance in policy
really depends a lot on this upcoming
offensive that is expected from Ukraine.
Is that in fact the case?
How important and pivotal will this
upcoming offensive be in the decision
making process?
I do not want to speak for future
operations of the Ukrainian military.
I would never do that.
I wouldn't even do that
for American future operations.
We do expect that the Russians
are going to go on the offense here,
try to go on the offense here
in weeks and months ahead, and it's likely
that the fighting will get more vicious
and more bloodily more bloody.
We want to make sure that the Ukrainians
are able to defend themselves
against what we anticipate
will be Russian offensive operations.
And if they choose
to be able to successfully conduct
offensive operations of their own.
And so that's what's been behind all these
recent packages of support we provided.
You've seen a lot of ammunition
going in in recent weeks.
You'll continue to see that.
We want to make sure that they're ready
for those offensive operations
if they choose to conduct.
And, John, just to be clear, it's
the Ukrainian offensive
that I was actually referring to that
that's expected in the spring,
in the coming weeks ahead.
How much is riding on Ukraine's success
in terms of
what position the Biden administration
takes moving forward?
Right. No, no,
I definitely understood the question
and what I don't want to talk about.
Any potential offensive operations
conducted by the Ukrainians,
that's for them to decide
and for them to speak to
We just want to make sure
that they're ready to defend themselves.
And if they choose to go on the offense,
to do it and do it successfully.
And that's the key point.
We want them to be successful
on the battlefield so that if
and when President Zelensky is ready to
sit down at the negotiating table with Mr.
Putin and there's no signs that
that's in the offing
any time soon that he can be successful
at the negotiating table, too.
We want him to have as much strength
going into those discussions
as humanly possible.
That's why we're focused on making sure
that the Ukrainians continue to be
and beyond they have been extraordinarily
successful on the battlefield.
You know,
they've clawed back
more than 50% of the territory
that Russia took for them
in the early weeks and months of this war.
We want to see that success continue.
And that's what we're focused on
is the administration.
And final question, factoring in perhaps
the possibility that Vladimir Putin never
wants to sit down at the negotiating
go go shouting table earnestly, at least.
He certainly has shown
no indication of that, has he?
I mean, every everything
that he has been doing, just matching
his actions instead of his words.
I mean, everything you can see is
he wants to continue this war.
He wants to continue to to take away
Ukraine's independence, their sovereignty.
He wants to subsume Ukraine into Russia,
doesn't want them to exist anymore.
And the Ukrainians are fighting literally
for their independence.
We see no signs that Mr.
Putin is willing to slack off back offer
or sit down and have any discussions.
And you know what?
We'd all love to see the war end
certainly as soon as possible.
And if it has to end to a negotiated
settlement, as you rightly said,
when we started talking
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine.
Ukraine's got to be at the center
of that discussion.
They've got to be consulted.
Their perspectives
have to be viewed and understood.
But Mr.
Putin could end this war today
just by pulling his troops out of Ukraine.
Again, he's shown no signs of doing that,
which is why we've got to continue
to support Ukraine on the battlefield.
All right, John Kirby,
thank you so much for your time.
We appreciate it. You bet.